kanye west's new album is officially
still not here
but you know who is here two-time emmy
winner ron cephas jones my man thank you
for coming to play thank you for having
me
as a number two you as beautiful as
always here we're going to have some fun
here at the london west hollywood i do
want to talk about truth be told we're
going to talk a little this is us
because you got a lot going on you're a
busy man but first we have to unpack
kanye's album listening party did he
really light himself on fire
and he may have even remarried his ex
it was a weird event very weird event no
childhood
kim kardashian there to support her uh
hubby are we watching a marriage happen
right now in front of all these people
in soldier field oh et can confirm it's
kim kay all right six months after she
filed for divorce kim was hidden under
the veil of this balenciaga couture
wedding gown for west grand finale where
he removed his headscarf grinned and
then cut to black
kim says chloe raved about the wild
moment confused fans lit up twitter
wondering if kimye is actually back
together our source won't go that far
and instead tells e.t kim and kanye
quote still think of themselves as a
family unit and are continuing to
support each other both personally and
professionally
oh and twitter wasn't the only thing lit
last night
yeah kanye appeared to set himself
ablaze getting extinguished right before
kim emerged and there were other
surprising and controversial guests i
keep it clean
but it could get messy behind kanye
embattled musicians marilyn manson and
de baby who replaced jay-z's rap in this
track from west's last listening event
this might beat her return utter throne
threw me out like i'm garbage huh many
fans expressed outrage one called the
trio the canceled avengers it was the
baby's first collaboration since the
rapper's homophobic remarks and marilyn
manson's first since multiple women
accused him of sexual assault claims
manson denies it also happened on the
same stage as this surprise opener
that sure looks like kim's kids north
and saint standing on the porch a
recreation of kanye's childhood home the
meaning behind all of this imagery we're
told it was honoring the past purifying
hence the fire and moving on the 44 year
old still hasn't released donda the
album named after his late mother does
he come to you before and get your
approval beforehand do you guys do that
yet
[Music]